- We're about to
go to the meetup.
I called a meetup.
DRock, you can show
some of the content
that I put out.
It's going to be 20 people.
I'm going to go outside
and do it in the street.
(crowd cheering)
(triumphant rock music)
- [Gary] Hey! Yeah!
(crowd cheering)
Perfect, let's do it.
This is what I do.
I'm sure DRock
picks this up a lot.
I just rub my left glut
on sharp shit all the time.
It makes me feel better.
I got some shit
going on there.
I stretch, I roll.
I got the ball.
I got the I don't know
what they call it.
It's at every gym,
the kind of Tootsie Roll thing.
I roll on that.
I got the ball, lacrosse ball.
I stretch. I yoga.
It's getting better.
It was a disaster
two years ago.
Just utter disaster.
It's getting better.
Tomorrow's the big
Vayner World event
which will be great,
which I'm really
looking forward to.
(crowd cheering)
And just having some
great, great business meetings.
A lot of agency stuff.
Spoke at an amazing
all time great agency.
I sit on panels and all these
fancy fucking places now
ARA, IRR, fuckin' Cannes, right?
And I listen to people
and I get to know them
because we're in the
green room together
for a coffee for an
hour before the panel.
And then eventually, you're out
at the fucking Facebook party
and you see that person,
get a drink.
It's blown me away how
many of these people
when you get a
couple cocktails in to them
say to me things like
Gary, you're right.
(audience laughter)
How many of you
saw "The Big Short"?
The movie. Raise your hands.
I'm just curious.
I swear to god when I
watched that movie
I was like holy shit this is
the advertising industry.
Everybody knows it
and everybody's in on it.
When I look around
the room this is not
80 year old white men.
Like all of you know.
- Yeah.
- That's it.
There's nothing else
that matters to me.
- Yeah.
- That's why I bring up
"The Big Short" because
everybody knew on Wall Street.
- It was funny about 10 minutes
in I was like I just watched
"The Big Short" on Sunday
and I was like what if
that's the big short
based on it.
- That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
Good to see you, man.
- Thanks again.
- Stay well.
Halfway through a
beautiful day in London.
Everybody's commenting.
I said that DRock
brought the good weather.
Not caught on film,
DRock tried to use the wrong
pass at the train station.
Not a very good traveler
between the missed
flight in Australia
and holding me up
at the train station.
'Cause you literally
used a different pass, DRock.
You can talk, you're a big boy.
- Your hotel room key.
Oh man.
Just much love to everybody.
Hope you're enjoying the series.
We're enjoying it.
It's becoming so weird.
This has become way too normal
for when I know people.
The level of jokes
that are happening
between my friends,
my contemporaries,
my acquaintances and
definitely my competitors
and people that
don't like my stuff as much.
The level of narcissism
around somebody following
you around but I will
take all that on because
I'm a big fucking boy.
I'll take that all on for the
hundreds of emails
from all of you that
have emailed and say
this is a process that
has allowed you to learn.
No #AskGaryVee,
no white paper on Slideshare,
no keynote has taught
you more than seeing it.
Seeing it and so that,
that one email from all
the 18 year old and
the 44 year old.
You guys know who you are.
Those emails, those comments
that oxygen trumps all
the stuff that I know is
going on around me.
But to the point,
it's getting weird
how normal this
has become DRock.
Like I've really toned
you the fuck out.
It's making it cool.
It's making it cool so
good talk today.
This morning too.
It's fun to be there.
Alright, let's get back
to work, DRock.
(thumping drums)
- London, 10 P.M. start
tonight I've decided.
10 P.M. SoHo area,
more details to come.
- What's the plan?
- [Alex] Literally nobody knows
not even Gary.
- [Gary] I don't know either.
Is it bad?
- We just went through it.
- It's big?
- Yeah. About 200 people.
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
-[DRock] No.
- No.
Alright London,
SoHo Square Garden
on the corner of
SoHo and Frith, right?
Oh no, SoHo and Frith?
Yeah, SoHo and Frith.
I have a scary feeling
a lot of people will
show up to this.
That is so crazy.
Did you see this?
We've been getting some snaps
that makes us feel there's
going to be a little bit more.
London, I'm humbled.
I love you.
To create some
clarity about tonight,
yes, the park is
going to be closed.
We're just going
to meet outside.
Like on the corner.
That's how I'm rolling.
DRock, you're going to
need to look at what
I just saw.
Fuck.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, this is going to
end up a little bit
bigger than we thought.
Fuck me.
Thanks for being here.
DRock, help me, DRock.
Hey!
(crowd cheers)
Yeah!
Holy fuck.
Alright, let's do it.
I started to see way
too much chatter
of people not being
able to make it.
Maybe we'll meet like
20 or 30 people in the corner.
Kinda misjudged it a little bit.
(crowd laughter)
- Yo, what's up guys?
My name is Daniel Dennehy.
I do freestyle football and
I also make music.
I do like hip hop
beats and stuff.
DRock has actually
used some of my beats
in Gary's videos before.
Just want to say thanks to Gary
for coming out here.
He's been so generous
with his time and just
making sure he
signs every book,
takes every picture.
Thanks a lot and yeah
if you guys want to
add me on Snapchat
DanielSnaps91. Had to throw
in the right hook or Gary
would kill me so there you go.
Go follow me on Snapchat
and yeah, thanks everybody for
coming as well 'cause it's
been a really cool vibe.
So yeah.
- Yes, guys DRock's here!
Go to DRock!
Alex, what the fuck?
DRock, take some of this action.
Holy shit.
Guys, I am so humbled.
Fuck.
Thank you, bro.
- I've been following GaryVee
since Wine Library really.
I was a social media
strategist for six years
so everything he says. I love
the character. It's amazing.
- Gary's been a huge
inspiration to me
in terms of digital
marketing and social media
and Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
has probably made us,
I can't really say the exact
amount but a six-figure
sum in terms of the
strategies that we've deployed.
It's safe to say.
I'm here to say
hi and thank you.
I was here to get
my book signed but
this is just crazy busy.
- I'm gonna wait 'cause it's
only going to take me a second.
Fuck school if
you're an entrepreneur.
- [Crowd] Yeah!
- My name's Ross Tester.
I've traveled three hours
here from Nottingham.
I'm an entrepreneur
and university as well.
I'm here because last year
my friend Carlito introduced
me to Gary Vaynerchuk.
Ever since I understood
the hustle and how hard
it is to break through
and get involved in business.
Ever since, I've started
my own little company,
street promotion company,
and also I've raised
£10,000, over £10,000
last year in three weeks
work for a close charity of mine
which is the
Teenage Cancer Trust.
- I look at losing
as a positive
mainly because everybody
here doesn't like losing
'cause they're worried
what other people
think about their loss.
- [Man] They're programmed.
- I don't give a fuck
what other people
think about my "L".
It's my "L".
You go worry about yourself.
This is my "L" and the
reason people don't like
losses is not so much
they don't like losses,
they're worried about
what everybody else
thinks about their loss.
That's the fucking gear.
- [Man] Real. I love that.
I love that. I love that.
- [Gary] Awesome man.
- I've been following Gary
for a good three to four years.
I'm honestly probably
his biggest follower.
I'm a student of
his philosophies.
I've learned so much
from his concept of
emotional intelligence
and self-awareness.
You know it, I ride with
Gary to the end.
That energy, it works so
well with me.
I hope one day,
some how that I can
mimic the presence that he has.
You know?
- [Crowd and Gary] Happy
Birthday to you,
Happy Birthday
dear (grumbling),
- [Gary] I hate giving advice
that I don't know.
Like self-awareness.
I don't know how to teach
you self-awareness. I don't
know how I got gratitude.
It just happened.
I'm in tune with my feelings.
I don't think I
figured that out.
There was no 9-step process to
get in tune with my feelings.
I'm just in tune with my
feelings and because
I'm in tune with my feelings,
I know how thankful I am.
I know how lucky I am.
Some of you have
heard me say this before,
you know how rare it is
to become a human?
(crowd laughter)
- What you mean?
- What do I mean?
I mean the math around actually
becoming a human being is
fucking insane.
You've won.
You did it.
You did it and so I
think about shit like that.
I think about shit like
what if my family died.
I think about what I actually
care about and then
that makes me happy.
Everybody is grateful
for different things.
I'm grateful for health,
and then I'm grateful
for the talents
that I was given.
It's easy for me to be grateful.
Just like it's easy for a lot
of you to look at the negative.
I have negative
people in my life.
I have negative family members.
They look at something
and it's a negative.
I just don't know that gear.
I don't fucking give negativity
or my losses the respect.
I don't respect it.
Yeah man.
- My girlfriend is pissed
but it's worth it.
(Gary laughing)
Can we take a selfie?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- You're a fucking legend.
- Tell her I'm sorry.
-Victoria.
- Victoria, I'm sorry.
This is a one time thing.
He's with you every night.
(laughter)
Right? That's what I'm saying.
Victoria, stop hogging him.
Thanks for coming man.
- Thanks.
- Let's do it. Hi.
- Hi!
- How've you been?
- Good, how are you?
- How long ago was that?
- That was September.
- God, we did a meet up in
September. There was like
seven people there.
Shit can change quick.
- [Man] What's happening
next time?
- Yeah. Who knows.
How you doing?
- Good.
- Thanks for waiting.
So ask away Realers.
What do you want to know?
See you tomorrow.
- Awesome.
- Good to see you.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
- I really appreciate it. I wish
I had a question for you but
I've been sitting here--
- Listening's a lot.
I know you got up high early.
- I know I ran around I was
like oh shit everyone's coming.
Go around the outside.
Just wanted to say
I'm feeling you. I've seen
people here tell you that
they've known you from
Wine Library, I haven't.
I've known you from the
last six months.
- Yes.
- And I can't get enough
of it, man. It's cool.
- Thank you, man.
- I really appreciate that.
- Thank you, brother.
I appreciate it.
- I look forward
to following you further.
- You too, man. Thank you for
hanging out for so long today.
Thank you.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Wasn't 30.
- Was not 30.
- It was not.
- I lost that bet.
You weren't right either.
He said 50.
- [DRock] I said 30.
- [Alex] Hard to put a
number on it.
It's a lot of fucking people.
- Were people walking by like
what the fuck?
- Yeah.
- What did you say?
- I was literally
saying Justin Bieber.
(Gary laughs)
(triumphant rock music)